this week we've got horse-girl
computer virus alert and Belle resort I
already know where Joe's mind went horse
horse show [ __ ] what did you say I
was thinking about maybe she's got a
long face I was thinking about burial
mounds or just in general just in
general I wasn't listening grails burial
mound yeah Emperor's used to use big
burial mounds to represent their power
this story is about a Norwegian woman
who has gone viral recently for her
ability to run and jump like a horse are
you talking about metaphorically or a
literal like on all fours like she can
act like a horse or she got hops like
LeBron James
I saw the one where the lady acts like a
dog wrong video [ __ ] right now
Oh literally that's tight good skills
actually this is the dumbest thing in
the world but it takes a lot of skills
oh you'll a hundred percent practicing I
kid you [ __ ] not right now that girl
has no friends exactly I thought she was
trying to pretend she's a dog cuz I saw
a different video of her and a dog
running their gatherin chasing each
other there is no way you develop a
skill like that if you have friends yeah
or a TV yep there's there some skills
out there that when you get really good
at them you know the only way is because
you're on friends yep there's like
there's no other reason why 100% cuz if
she had friends she would have got her
ass and that's not a social activity keV
like hey yo you want to come go practice
my horse stuff practising horse jumping
no way I saw this one video
Russian girl she was neglected and in
left in the backyard with the dogs
so she was raised by dogs and then she
thinks she's a dog and she like crawls
on all fours like a dog and she walks
like that - does she pee like a dog are
her bones off it's like a fifth element
that's reminds me of I don't know I
don't know she kind of like his animal
like she was she was in the onion yeah
yeah I know but like maybe I talk about
when Chris Tucker's gay she just reminds
me of a dog the bad reference it's a
pretty bad reference like it fit though
I just wanted you guys to pick it up
from there I'll like house gate Chris
Tucker have anything to do with this
it's kinda like a robot movie like a
robot okay well she was four years old
she said that she really loved dogs she
wanted to be a dog okay oh she also knew
she liked horses and so she just used
what she had learned from watching these
animals she um is she special not that I
know of
okay how [ __ ] dare I just wanted to
know the way she's explaining is like
well she knew she liked dogs and she
always wanted to be a dog it's you she's
like horses she wanted to be a horse so
you know she did it you never wanted to
be an oboe I did when I was five oh
she's from Norway Norway and so she's
just gone viral because of her skills
people are still fun that's what of what
a loose word for that that is a skill
though I guess so she's really good at
that yeah she can jump high and land on
her [ __ ] legs but if she starts a new
Olympic sport it's embarrassing but
she's good at it does she have a job or
that's all she does that's all I know
about her
honey we're moving on to the next story
a laptop that has been infected with six
of the most dangerous computer right
viruses in history was sold at an
auction to an anonymous buyer for 1.3
million dollars why so they could infect
the world trying to give [ __ ] AIDS
virus through computers that's amazing a
[ __ ] I don't think that's how it works
your age of computers oh it's sold for
1.3
just as history so it was actually
stolen as art so this artist Oh got all
these viruses to be put into this laptop
this 2008 Samsung and C 10 laptop
running Windows see they can't do it on
an apple cuz that should just wouldn't
even take that's right
oh that's right we love Apple 4 pcs look
at David's face look at David's face you
know what I have to get an Apple phone
though you forgot what it's called I
have to get a pair because this piece of
[ __ ] right here is called an Apple watch
why not i watch it should be my walkie
instead of ITV's so it's not called
Apple phone now kids nope iPhone I need
to get me one of them little toffee
things right there you do I can't text
you anymore it's kind of annoying now
because yet not to you
I neither were files it's the most
glorious [ __ ] file on earth they do
this thing where they don't allow like
like high data transfers between Android
and Apple yeah and I need that for work
so especially in group text it's so
annoying when there's Android users in
the group text and they try to send like
a video or a picture it's like this tiny
green hiney thing remember that time in
japan when you're able to text all of us
I can't text his phone number on my
phone anymore exactly the same problem
female yeah same [ __ ] that's what the
DMD don't let yo David can you [ __ ]
text mich it's crazy fine break because
I had to text him with Muriel in the
conversation like that's the only way it
would go through or I had to text them
through my laptop well how come I can
text them I don't know by text David it
goes to it's weird turns blue
immediately even if I'm like no you
change your settings man I need to get a
new phone yeah yes going to get a new
phone this week I'm gonna get it on
Friday [ __ ] always this week tomorrow
this week tomorrow oh yeah that is
tomorrow okay I'm gonna get it
tomorrow's and Apple phone five I'm
gonna get an 8 I'm gonna get up there's
a tad Matt huh I'm gonna get an iPhone 8
plus that's what I have I think
have an old one if you want do you hold
on to you no I gave it to my brother Oh
have a lot let me get that a-plus then
because I like the A+ you have a lot
yeah why do you have so many I don't
know what to do with them and I'm like I
bought it I'm gonna keep this [ __ ] and I
keep it I'm like I'm gonna sell it later
and I'm like I want to sell it
give me your plus I want that one and
you're not a hoarder I gave them a rout
I give up to all my friends and stuff
I'm not you can go to my house right now
and you'll see that I'm not a hoarder
at all I'm coming over don't you got a
bigger house so it doesn't look like ya
taller ceilings can you can we set the
record straight let you see my feet as
underwear in this big drawer this much
place okay now be a pride now amaya
order that said it's trading don't [ __ ]
around on your said you promised okay
this is intervention Emma what is going
on why are you having a nervous
breakdown what the [ __ ] wrong with I
love being a neat person yeah I love
being tall doesn't mean I'm tall
relative to who though I don't know
because everyone's just normal because
for me it finally use it for three
months I go it out they finally do
something for three months I throw it
away okay we're gonna start a new
conversation okay we need to finish this
conversation TV show about it over there
that's a world-class collector collector
a museum Pirie Anna a curator museum
curator a museum Jamali a National
Museum of niceness of [ __ ] hey hey hey
hey that's why I have relics that I
still have today this girl just told me
that she goes through your stuff that
she knows that you don't [ __ ] use and
then she'll throw it away but two years
later you'll look like
I told her to prove a point cuz I'm like
can we throw us away and I'll ask him
for like a good five months ago this
thing weighs like 'nygh use it and he
never uses it and after a year I throw
it away I think he doesn't notice except
for a couple times like years later
it'll be like where's this one random
thing and I try to pretend like you
never had it and then he believes if he
goes you're probably right you're
absolutely right you thought about
getting that but it's gonna be an
antique one day and you just ruined it
it's a family relic no it's the [ __ ]
like monitors that he thinks are still
good but they're like from the 1980s and
he's like that could have been a monitor
I'm like just buy a new monitor it's not
a big deal you could buy a model it's a
collector's item 1980s ease that they
could exist if you donate it to the
museum
if he was as artsy as you Joe I would
maybe consider it but see that's what
does he do he just one point something
million yo Mary all has that type of
[ __ ] so yes I had this bold like Visio
she a hoarder well she wanted this old
vizio tv and I was like this TV right
now you can't even buy it for $12 yeah
you can't even try to sell it yeah but
we could still use it and I literally
just chucked it out as she was upset
yeah
but I found the TV on Craigslist for
free right now one of our first fights
was I was trying to get rid of this big
Toshiba TV that he had from 2005 and he
was trying to tell me his top of the
line this was 2013 when this was
absolutely it's not worth anything he's
like this is top of the line he was like
so adding it took up half the [ __ ]
living room because we lived in a studio
and then he went to his brother's house
and played Grand Theft Auto it just came
out like the GTA 5 and he was shocked at
how much better much better they put 20
years later he's gonna be she's gonna
see out of Museum and go look look at
how much it sold for he tried to sell it
for $50 on Craigslist
nobody nobody wants and he put it on the
street and no one would even take it you
gotta wait til maturity happens until it
becomes a classic Joe you know what I
love Steve's old [ __ ] I'm gonna give it
to you it's like the TV I'm gonna
collect
remember I don't collect that kind of
stuff mm-hmm anyway so this laptop here
it can't so they're saying that they
disabled the USB port and it also has
this thing where you can't connect to
the internet like they made it so you
can't connect it to you cool yeah but
people are saying like anyone with basic
computer knowledge I can take a computer
part apart could get these viruses which
is true viruses there well they are
responsible for billions of dollars and
they're about 95 billion dollars in
financial damages worldwide that's
awesome viruses caused so yeah now it's
a art thing that is pretty artsy yeah
but someone spent that much money on
these viruses that's wonderful but not
as much money as the viruses costed
businesses 95 billion yeah yes so these
viruses it's I love you virus the mydoom
virus so big virus wanna cry virus which
happened recently that one affected
200,000 computers across 150 countries
goin that one was where it held some Mac
computers yeah so it held users data as
ransomware and so they're saying that
unless you pay a ransom you won't have
access to your data and so this affected
the National Health thank from the UK
the NHS it was a hundred million dollars
in damages oh [ __ ] who got all the money
you don't know the hackers yeah so they
there were people paying the ransom
because they needed like health care
health care system you know they eight
times a day this number has been calling
me this week for it's from the social
Social Security Administration saying
they suspended my social security number
for suspicious activity and then you cuz
the first like million times I ignored
it and then I'm like I'm not talk to
these people tell them to stop [ __ ]
calling me so I clicked it and it's
always this Indian chick that picks up
but she's like check hello Social
Security
and I'm like yeah I don't want my social
security number to be suspended so what
do I do and she goes okay I can help you
but these yards so it shows the gear D
number that's funny
and I'm like five five five five five
and then she hangs up she knows you're
pranking her yeah yeah and then I did it
the next time I was just asking her to
take me off the list and she hung up and
then like they just keep calling me name
number a different number it's a it's so
many different numbers yeah it's a
million just to let you know you're
going to die so if you don't want to die
give me five dollars I would pay you
five dollars to have them stop calling
me cuz it's so annoying it's always like
didn't they do it well because they do
an area code that you're familiar with
yeah so they're trying to make you
that's how I started now there's just
like random 1-800 numbers I don't pick
up numbers I usually don't but they kept
leaving voicemails they can't believe
they filled up my voicemail inbox
because they keep leaving voicemails but
it's just an automated thing that's like
brass one you want to keep your social
security number it is annoying and if
you ask them where they're from they
always say Austin Texas I'm from Austin
alright now for our last story mmm Taco
Bell has announced that they will take
over a resort in Palm Springs
Taco Bell Wonderland so they're calling
it the bell sounds pretty quick hotel
yeah Hotel will they there take a break
okay yeah no more food things for me
dude tim has the hook up with talk about
I'm gonna pass it on yeah passes are you
guys doing it I want to go I want hot
cold Bell the bass just gonna fight joke
love on Del Taco
oh [ __ ] I'll infiltrate that [ __ ] now go
balls got so much better marketing
they're like the stoner marketing really
gets but they don't follow me you like
tacos yeah yeah cuz that's an easy
follow no it tastes better
to follow you I used to like Taco Bell
but they changed man Oh their salsas
changed all the only thing I like is
that the repay you know what I just had
recently
Tam's oh what's tired now like in the
bag no it's a burger joint oh they're my
parents before I was like a hood burger
joint or some [ __ ] like that but that is
delicious man where it's like Denny's
but all to go food it's all fast food
but it's like dad where is that it's
like in Bellflower Montebello Compton
paramount I think I know you're talking
probably do especially but were you it
yes especially week that was a small
where we would all hang out and get
pregnant out right yeah yes I open 24/7
I remember being there during the time
when ghost riding the whip was popular
and people be doing that that's probably
where it is like tan is kind of like
like a kind of burger joint but it's
good so it's like the Tommy's a valet
like that
yeah but Tommy's isn't Tommy there's a
team Tam's kind of is a team now but
it's only like in this area though oh
it's pretty [ __ ] good I want to hear
about the Bell taking over yes stupid
well that's all I got
oh wait you don't know is there gonna be
a casino
don't know because they all know haven't
I got [ __ ] you guys also to continue the
story you [ __ ] the only thing that
they're saying is that everything from
guest rooms to breakfast and poolside
cocktails would be infused with a Taco
Bell twist everything gonna smell like
[ __ ] sour cream and [ __ ] being that
and twist
cocktails there will be Taco Bell
branded robes hot sauce packet pool
floats and an on-site gift shop filled
with exclusive taco apparel they put too
much sour cream in their tacos way too
much you know sour cream booked an
appointment at the salon which will have
Taco Bell inspired nail art fades and a
braid bar something about their cheese -
it's all laying oh you like those taco
cheese though oh I like from Del Taco is
this chicken stock yeah
that's just pretty bomb the first thing
but Taco Bell has the chalupa all in
everything they have the chalupa the
Mexican pizza I like their red sauce
nasty bro like the [ __ ] tomatoes are
always hot is hot in the bean the
[ __ ] it's nothing Mexican about it
but there's two layers of chips with
beans and ground whatever kind of meat
that is and then the cheese on the top I
like the Saba which is just one thought
I'm and beans and I need the two layers
to get the crispy because by the time it
gets to your house its soggy as [ __ ]
that's why it's gross it doesn't remind
me of the 90s so [ __ ] Taco Bell
dang go to hell
[Music]
[Music]